on est dans l'idée que nous sommes des
recruteurs et vous êtes de vendre pour
représenter par contre ne venant pas de
questions voilà ce que je pouvais
toujours bas mon nom mon prénom suivi de
vos pieds 3 passes et l'image avant
quelques une vanne ou de 21 ans
je suis ensuite l'école à 16 ans je suis
entré en contre professionnalisation
dans le bâtiment et après bien des
expériences juanito solaire et non plus
2 qualifiant tu les as et des
distributeurs de prospectus
depuis 2002 possible démission de
l'information sur vos expériences vos
compétences et s'est développée
peut-être un petit peu puissant je te
rappelle en tout dans le bâtiment je
travaille beaucoup dans un bâtiment et
puis mon attention mais je fais tout ce
qu'on me dit de faire ça te prend le
poste aussi que c'est quoi quel est
votre projet aujourd'hui travailler oui
si on quel métier bas de préférence aux
produits change est bien d'accord
et pourquoi
que ça s'arrête jamais j'aime bien le
temps passe vite